Hi, and welcome to another Rawkode Bite here
at the Rawkode Academy.
Today, I wanna share with you my top
five tips and tricks for shell proficiency.
Number one, switching to the previous directory.
If you spend a lot of your time
in a terminal, you probably jump around directories
a fair bit.
Did you know you can use a c
d dash
to jump to the previous directory?
That's tip number one.
Tip number two, reverse history search.
You probably also type a fair number of
commands on your terminal.
Firstly, you can just use the up and
down arrow keys to navigate your command history.
This is great for commands that you know
you executed recently.
However,
if your command is too far back,
this gets rather cumbersome.
For this, you can use control r.
Pressing control r push you into a history
search. Type something from your previous command and
watch it come front and center.
Tip number three, special variables.
Most shells provide some special variables. For instance,
did you know that the exit code of
the last command
is available via dollar sign question mark?
Dollar sign exclamation mark has a process ID
of the last executed command
and dollar dollar is the process ID of
the current command,
which is probably your shell.
These are pretty useful when you start automating
tasks with scripts.
Tip number four,
find files
fast.
The find command is fantastic when you don't
really know where the file you're looking for
lives or even which file you're looking for.
First, you can find files based on types.
You can look for files, directories,
links,
or even socket.
Next, you can filter files based on the
owner
or the group.
And how about finding empty files
or files modified within the last two days?
And what if you even want to delete
them all,
or execute
a random command?
I could go on and on, but really,
you should just go check out Veinte.
Tip number five, control codes.
There are a whole bunch of control codes
that you can use on the command line.
Control a will take you all the way
back to the start of the line.
Control e will take you to the end.
If you want to delete the entire line,
you can use control u.
My favorite, control l. This clears your screen.
No more typing clear.
And lastly, the one that everybody hates because
they press it accidentally,
control s.
This will stop your terminal showing any output.
You will think your terminal has frozen.
You'll then go and Google for the shortcut
and see that it's control q.
And it doesn't matter that I've told you
it's control q, you're gonna forget.
I promise.
That's my top five tips
for shell proficiency.
If you like this video, let me know
and I'll drop five more.
Have a great day.